Camogli looks just like any other town on the Italian coast.
The little colored houses face the sea and the sun shines on them.
But, if you look carefully, you'll see something very interesting.
In the town of Camogli, there are many things that seem real but they're not.
This fishing village near Genoa is full of trompe l'oeil,...
...a type of art in which nothing is what it seems to be.
For example, in this particular village, windows open in solid walls.
There seems to be elaborate stonework, but it isn't stonework, it's paint.
And while some flowers die, other flowers live for years.
Why? Because they're painted on the building.
In the past, Camogli's fishermen used to paint their houses in bright colors and unusual designs.
They did this so that they could easily see their homes from the water.
Then, in the 1700s, this style of art became a way to make small, simple buildings look grand...
...and seem like they cost a lot of money.
Now, there are still thousands of trompe l'oeil houses in this area,...
...but only a few artists still paint them.
Raffaella Stracca is one of these artists.
She learned this style of painting from her grandmother.
Raffaella uses a mixture of old and new methods to create her work.
You find a lot of these painted facades in the area of Liguria a lot.
But for a while, it seemed like no one was doing them anymore.
It takes a long time to become a good trompe l'oeil painter.
Raffaella has worked for 20 years to be able to paint stone so well...
...that it looks real even if you're close to it.
Like most painters, Raffaella learned trompe l'oeil from other artists, not in a school.
But these days, there are fewer artists, fewer teachers, and fewer places to learn the technique.